it was with shock and utter dismay that
we have been watching developments in
Ukraine over the last 24 hours there are
no circumstances that can justify such
scenes of violence we condemn in the
strongest terms the use of violence as a
way to solve the political and
institutional crisis we believe the
political leadership of the country has
the responsibility to ensure the
protection of fundamental rights and
freedoms we call on all sides to put an
end to violence immediately and to
engage into a serious dialogue we
believe that is the only way to respond
to Democratic aspirations of Ukrainian
people as you know your opinion has been
offering a sincere assistance to
facilitate political dialogue between
both sides and also to deescalate the
situation we continue to believe that we
need in Ukraine constitutional reform
formation of new inclusive government
and also to create the conditions for
democratic elections these are the only
ways to have a solution for the
political crisis we have also made it
clear to Ukraine that we are ready to
support Ukraine on its road for reforms
for democracy for stability and for
prosperity and we have made also clear
that our offer of political association
and economic integration remains on the
table and of course this does not
constitute the final goal in our
cooperation but we have also made it
clear that your opinion will respond to
any deterioration on the ground that's
why we expect that targeted measures
against those responsible for violence
and use of excessive force can be agreed
by our member states and we hope that
they consider this as a matter of
urgency as it was already proposed by
the High Representative vice president
of the Commission Cathy Ashton